tr let's hit it oh what a Brennan I got
a debate club question for you who do
you think I wanted to fight in their
prime Chuck Norris Cole jean-claude Van
Damme all right gang gang buzz Oh Oh
got them cheeky chi-chi's out showing
that but at the end there boy yeah Bret
what's his name Trent Reznor Tristan
Robinson Tristan Rob Tristan flexing my
cheeks bro where's he from
he didn't say mmm oh yeah you don't say
after you show your ass to somebody over
video yeah so where you from I like that
move yeah you spend us bro yeah dude
a flat ass moon I like that flatter me
that's that flat earth moon that's that
Eddie Bravo that dude he's got to Eddie
Bravo's in the back of his pants - flat
cheeks what was the question
Oh chocolate our trip Liddell Chuck
Norris drunk Claude Van Damme go ahead
bro oh I have to go on this one I'll say
uh Chuck Norris hmm because Chuck Norris
is a kind of man he look you know he's
like a step daddy that also can fight
pretty and fight at a high level you
know and he can kind of be in any world
Chuck Norris can you can see him one
time in like a oh he's in a suit oh he's
on a tractor oh he's you know selling
insurance you know he's in a Western
yeah he's a claims adjuster he's in a
Western you know he's banging Suzanne
Somers he's on the Tony good gazelle
freestyle or you know I'm saying right
he can [ __ ] attack from anywhere
where is jean-claude I think is a little
bit more limited you know john cloud has
that does the splits in his underwear
oh trying to fake tans always trying to
[ __ ] you like time pretty yeah then had
the coke habit you know I'm saying like
you know martial artists bro Chuck
Norris don't even drink or do coke it's
true and he gets high off of mmm kicking
ass if I'm taking that dude bro
Chad Norris all day he's a you know he's
I think was a legit black belt in
jujitsu jean-claude Van Damme I he says
he had some fights but it's not
documented at all lot of fake Frank Dux
bro yeah he might hope better actor
jean-claude Van Damme bro Lionheart
bloodsport kickboxer
cyborg dude when I was growing up
bloodsport was the only movie they
we go to the movie store they had this
place called past video and there's
shrimp in the movies do well can we go
there
Oh get a [ __ ] pound I tried no peel
and eat we go get a pound of shrimp and
a [ __ ] and but the only movie they
had one time they had seven copies of
[ __ ] bloodsport
you're damn right they did they call a
movie when the greatest movies of all
time
okay USA yeah and you know here's
another thing now he also as a senior
citizen male model and a lot of men
can't even do that so that's cool but
when you're when your best thing is uh
the splits you're missing out on life
bro like all he does is the splits
everywhere that's true he's the mayor of
Marina del Rey - I used to live there
and see the man he drew up the biggest
drunk lock my damn fan of all play how
big is he when you see him not a big man
not a big man at all that's the other
reason I take middle-sized man you're
bigger than he is
Wow yeah I mean your shoulders are
skinnier but yeah yeah but that's
because I had a fever recently mmm um
okay Chuck Norris all day what's people
saying 63% say Chuck Norris Chuck Norris
that's what's up gang gang they know
what's up
[Music]
the king nothing
[Music]